منصات التواصل ما لحقت تنع وتحزن على فهد
الحيان الا وفاجئها خبر محزن اخر برحيل
المخرج السوري الكبير هشام شربت جي
والملقب في الوسط بالشيخ الكار هشام شربجي
رحل عن 75 سنه بعد سلسله انتكاسات صحيه
بسبب جلطه دماغيه من عامين الراحل قضاء
اكثر من 25 سنه في الاخراج كان فيها احد
اعمده ومؤسسين نهضه الدراما السوريه
واخرجوا العديد من الاعمال اللي تحولت
لايقونات مثل عائله خمس نجوم وسته وسبعه
وثمانيه نجوم ويوميات مدير عام واسرار
المدينه وجميل وهناء واحلام ابو الهناء
وغيرها وغيرها من الاعمال نجوم سوريا
والعالم العربي نعو الراحل عبر حساباتهم
وكثار منهم بداوا يحطوا صورهم وذكرياتهم
معاه ووجهوا كلام لابنته المخرجه المعروفه
رشاش
وتفعلكم او في تفاعلكم احنا كمان بنتقدم
باحر التعازي لاسره الراحل هشام شوربه
جيوب بالاخص ابنته رشا طبعا الله يرحمه
ويصبر العائله